[Music]
new at four do you know of a grandparent
raising their grandchild or
grandchildren they sacrifice a lot to do
so and a local woman is hoping you'll
help them through her special project
we're just groups of people that care
about these grandparents joyce eatman is
well known in las vegas
we first met her nearly 10 years ago as
our very first acts of kindness
recipient we here at channel 8 joyce
believe in what you're doing we want to
continue doing it recognizing her for
what she does to help others she's been
running a non-profit called lace ladies
advocating christian entertainment since
the 1990s and the grants for grand
project is an offshoot of lace that she
started 15 years ago all of our funds
are generated through contributions
donations and fundraisers and i tell you
since last year down down down we're not
just not getting any financial help all
while the need has grown during the
pandemic she has 400 grand families in
her database she can't help them all but
every year tries to reach at least 50
especially the seniors with items not
covered by food stamps household items
they can't buy soap and
toothpaste deodorant they can't buy over
the counter
medications they can't buy bed linen she
also likes to provide them with a gift
card to a local grocery store to do some
shopping of their own